Stephen Crowder is a conservative
comedian who makes videos on YouTube
he's pretty popular is that close to
four million subscribers and tens of
millions of viewers his stuff isn't for
everyone but so if you don't like his
videos watch Colbert it's a free country
where he used to be the press is working
to change that a few days ago a writer
at voxcom demanded that YouTube banned
steven crowder why for the crime of
insulting him amazingly many in the
washington press corps agreed you
shouldn't be allowed to mock talentless
Vox writers they said apparently it's a
new addition to the First Amendment
turns out the Vox writer in question is
hardly a sympathetic figure hardly he's
got a long history of leveling racist
attacks online he's called for
physically assaulting people he
disagrees with politically even as he
winds about being oppressed himself he
is in other words a classic archetype on
the left he's a fascist posing as a
victim no sensible adult would take him
seriously and yet YouTube is obeying his
commands the company announced it will
de monetize steven crowder his YouTube
channel killing his business they did
this even though in a statement they
admitted that Crowder had broken no
rules Vox amazingly meanwhile released a
series of statements demanding that
YouTube censor Crowder entirely not just
D monetize him but bounce him off so
much for free were the press the real
question of the rest of us is why is
this allowed to continue let's stop
pretending platforms like Twitter and
Facebook and YouTube
these are the modern public square
obviously Congress has acknowledged them
as such section 230 the Communications
Decency Act gives tech companies special
immunity from being sued for defamation
or fraud immunity we don't have on this
channel for example and the purpose of
this is to allow quote true diversity of
political discourse
it's a high-minded cause the effect is
immunity and that immunity is worth tens
of billions of dollars it's one of the
reasons the owners of Twitter and
Facebook and Google are so rich you
guaranteed that to them through your
representatives in the Congress and yet
in return
these tech companies violate the terms
of the deal every minute of every day
they're not open forums their ongoing
exercises in control and censorship the
question is how long will the rest of us
stand for this Glenn Greenwald
co-founded the intercept and he joins us
thank then thanks so much for coming on
so you don't have to be a fan of steven
crowder or whatever or anyone to see
this as a threat a threat to one
person's speech is a threat to all of
our speech is it not yeah I mean I
personally find steven crowder to be
just a contemptuous [ __ ] as a
commentator I do think he's an infantile
bully witch and bigot which are not
words I easily invoke he didn't just
criticize Carlos masa he mocked him for
being gay and for being Latino you used
the Lisp and things to ridicule him
sends a lot of harassment his way but
that's the point Tucker is that
censorship advocates want our brains to
only go to that most primitive first
level of do we hate this person and are
we therefore glad that they're being
censored without thinking about the
framework being endorsed or the
consequences right that insu permit I
mean I personally it resonates a lot for
me because I've dealt with harassment
far greater than what Carlos maza is
complaining of I'm a gay man in a
country Brazil that just elected a
president driven by intense anti-gay
animus my husband's a member of Congress
and the oppositional party we've been
mocked and derided with our sexual
orientation not by a random youtubers
but by the president of the country
himself on Twitter and his family
members who are elected members of
Congress and it would never occur to me
to run to social media companies to beg
for censorship because in part it's just
something that comes with the territory
being a public figure but more so
because I don't want to live in a world
where our discourse is policed and
determined by benevolent overlords who
run Silicon Valley companies you know
we're always going to cater to the most
powerful faction that's what happened
here YouTube caved in not in defense of
the marginalized person
in defense of the powerful one the one
who despite being gay and Latino works
for a major media conglomerate and
that's what they're always gonna do is
defend the mob and defend the powerful
at the expense of those who are
marginalized is such a good point
they're defending the power really
quickly I just have to ask you so you
don't have immunity you don't have the
immunity that YouTube for example enjoys
was granted by Congress you you found it
a pretty big and well known site if you
libel someone you can be sued they're
immune from that why do they retain that
immunity that's a really good question
and the reason is is because originally
these companies like YouTube Google
Twitter our Facebook we're supposed to
be like AT&T which are just neutral
public platforms right so if steven
crowder wants to call someone using AT&T
and organize an anti vox rally nobody
expects AT&T to stop him because the
idea is it's just a platform for people
to use
that's what Silicon Valley companies
originally were supposed to be and they
got immunity for it
in reality this power to censor was not
one that they wanted it was one that was
foisted upon them amazingly largely by
journalists who were demanding that they
remove voices from the internet imagine
going into journalism and then begging
corporations to silence and censor
people that's the real reason they ended
up in this position so nicely put I got
actually quickly federal prosecutors
recently revealed an 18 count indictment
against WikiLeaks the founder Julian
Assange is being charged under the
Espionage Act for his role in helping to
release leaked government documents
you've been very close to the story from
day one and your point has been that
this could criminalize ordinary
journalism what do you mean well a lot
of your viewers probably remember that
under the Obama administration a lot of
journalists were targeted and called
criminals for working with sources
including James Rosen right who was
called the conspirator for working with
the source who leaked to him classified
material but at least they never went
out and actually criminalized the people
who published that material the Trump
Justice
partment has taken that step now by
saying that WikiLeaks is criminal not
because they stole the information they
didn't but because they published it and
I think we've all seen on the left and
right over the past several decades that
the CIA the NSA the FBI are agencies
that will abuse their power unless they
have great transparency shined on them
WikiLeaks has done that sometimes
angering the left sometimes angering the
right and that's why they want to
criminalize Julian Assange both to
punish him for bringing transparency to
the deep state but also to create a
theory hoping that everybody hates
Assange just like steven crowder and
therefore doesn't think about the
consequences that says if you're
somebody who publishes secret
information you can be turned into a
criminal and that's why it's so
dangerous to press freedom that is
that's the key point they pick someone
they whipped mob into a frenzy here's
the person you should hate and they
distract us from the consequences of
what they're doing the consequences to
us and I thank you Glenn Greenwald for
reminding us those consequences
appreciate it thanks doctor